une démocratie s'honore de faire de la
politique et qu'à un moment donné on
peut pas tout déléguer à un conseil
scientifique que les scientifiques ont
des choses à nous dire avec avec une
réalité ce qu'ils savent de quoi ils
parlent en tout cas de quoi il parle car
on peut l'espérer mais qu'à un moment
donné il ya des choix à faire il ya des
choix pour partie en tout cas aller
discuter ensemble et à faire une sorte
de balance
qu'est ce qu'on fait comment le fait qu
est-ce que l'on choisit et des gens
d'ailleurs âgées qui sont les premiers
quand même à faire attention qu'ils
savent qu'ils sont en risque
je rappelle que c'est pas l'âge qui est
le risque je pars avec un gain de 75 ans
qui fait du vélo tous les matins et que
et quelqu'un a un coeur qui bat à 65
il est moins en risque que quelqu'un de
25 ans qui a une mauvaise santé qu'il ya
un mode de fonctionnement différent
quelqu'un qui est touché par telle ou
telle maladie chronique qui a 40 ans
peut être touché par un fort diabète et
qui finalement est en risque bien plus
forts gains obtenus tout alors parlé de
rire et plaisir ainsi de suite mais ce
sont quand même les meilleurs
médicaments la vie le sourire le rire
les changes le partage c'est quand même
ce qui vous fait le plus de bien et
quand on prive des gens y compris pour
les protéger et condé si on sait ce qui
est bien pour eux parce qu'un des grands
problèmes quand même c'est
l'infantilisation a pas seulement des
vieux mais entre autres des vieux c'est
une certaine manière on infantilise un
petit peu tout le monde
attention faut pas faire comme ça mais
abandonné bazar et puis c'est aussi
choisir est allé voir quelqu'un en
faisant attention lui fait sans doute
bien plus de bien que au prétexte de
protéger ne pas aller le voir enfin pas
dire de faire n'importe quoi mais on a
besoin les uns des autres on a besoin de
celui là est sans doute que autour de ça
on a voulu avoir une vision une
philosophie prophylactique de la vie
quoi on va se protéger complètement
on va faire attention à tous les griffes
et non l'être humain est un virus et
c'est pas grave on part des choses mais
en se revoyant en échangeant en se
rencontrant en s'engueulant en
conversant dès lors on est dans une
relation disant pacifique
on se
et du bien et c'est ne pas voir les
autres qui la pire des choses
[Musique]